les 12 et 19 juin vous élirez votre
prochain député
emmanuel macron vient d'être réélu à
l'issue d'un duel qu'une majorité de
français ne voulaient pas ce quinquennat
s'ouvre malheureusement sans espérance
une chose est sûre nous ne pouvons pas
laisser les pleins pouvoirs à mâcher
macron l'assemblée nationale ne doit pas
rester le repaire de son fan club
député à 23 ans trop jeune diront
certains et vous savez on en voit bien
des gamins de 18 ans à la guerre moi je
veux être un soldat de la paix et dans
le tarn comme à paris contribuer à la
réconciliation des français parce qu'on
ne fait rien de bon si on est pas une
mais si je dois faire la guerre c'est à
ceux qui depuis tant d'années ont
aggravé les injustices condamnés à des
retraites de misère nos aînés à ceux qui
ont abandonné les travailleurs qui
croule sous les taxes et les petites
entreprises étouffé par la bureaucratie
il faut une fois pour toutes valoriser
le travail
encourager ceux qui se lèvent tôt pour
aller travailler ou pour chercher du
travail il faut rétablir l'ordre parce
que la sécurité c'est bien sûr la
première des libertés
j'ai des convictions solides elles se
résument bien dans la devise de la
république
croyez moi je ne serai pas un député aux
ordres je vous serai fidèle
si je devais vous donner une seule une
unique raison de voter pour moi c'est
que je me battrai pour vous de toutes
mes forces avec au coeur l'amour de mon
pays et le respect de chacun d'entre
vous
[Musique]
depuis plusieurs mois je vient à votre
rencontre des histoires bouleversantes
vous en avez du temps libre et je pense
à cette maman isolée qui touche 1280
euros par mois chaque jour elle prend sa
voiture pour aller travailler chaque
semaine elle doit faire un choix
remplir le frigo ou remplir son
réservoir
avec fierté elle m'a dit qu'elle ne
mangeait pas tous les jours pour que ses
deux enfants conservent leurs trois
repas quotidiens ce jour là j'ai compris
que je ne lâcherai pas je ne vous
lâcherai pas mes amis l'exploit est au
bout de nos efforts ensemble on va
renverser la table aujourd'hui j'ai
besoin de vous alors aidez moi